you know we're gonna start with a story
that is just absolutely incredible
actually some good news this morning
it's rare that we get to say everybody
survived after a crash this is the story
all 103 people aboard a Mexican airliner
survived when the plane slammed into the
ground shortly after takeoff Aeromexico
flight 24 31 was packed with 99
passengers four crew members when it
went down and burst into flames I mean
look at this picture this was in
northern Mexico investigators are still
trying to determine what caused the
crash
at least 80 people were hurt in the
crash 49 of them were taken to the
hospital two people including the pilot
are in serious but stable condition Kris
Van Cleave is tracking the latest
developments Kris good morning good
morning really a miraculous survivors
story people shown it at the airport
here for an Aeromexico flight we're
learning about the crash from us and
certainly expressed concern after
hearing about it now Aeromexico CEO says
the plane was 10 years old was quote
perfectly maintained and was last
serviced in February
Mexico's Civil Aviation Authority says
it could take months to determine the
cause this is what emergency crews
encountered when they arrived on the
scene the Embraer 190 largely intact but
on fire with some passengers still
inside the crash happened in Mexico's
northern state of Durango the flight was
headed to Mexico City
Durango's governor says the plane made
it off the ground but was hit by a gust
of wind as it left the runway causing
the plane to land abruptly on its left
wing and forcing the engines to catch
fire just a few hundred yards from
takeoff Lorenzo Nunez was a passenger on
the plane there was a strong explosion
that hit the plane he said we don't know
if it was a lightning bolt or a
mechanical problem we had just taken off
and the plane fell this woman explains
how she escaped the wreckage with her
son she said I was lucky enough to turn
around and there was a hole somewhere i
unbuckled my son's seatbelt and we got
out that way and jumped some passengers
described people being trapped at the
back of the smoke-filled plane and
helping others make it out of the flames
Ross aimer is a retired airline captain
it was a miracle that no one so far has
fatally been injured
I would say this would have been a one
in a hundred chance that we have no
fatalities really remarkable Embree air
the planes manufacturer has sent a team
to the crash site the US Embassy in
Mexico tells us they've not been able to
confirm if any Americans were on board
during those governor's says some of the
survivors actually wandered back to the
airport after the crash looking for
their loved ones
Alex Chris thanks it really is a miracle
right yeah I was thinking the same thing
them would have what a harrowing thing
to go to for all through go through for
all those passengers but you know live
as that woman said she just turns around
there's a hole in the plane she manages
to get out takeoff is a tricky part yes
we're the trickiest